27 people. They were boys with
their cars. Summer jobs. Oh my God.
Are you one of them?
He dressed up like a clown for them with
his face painted white and red and on
his best behavior in a
dark room on the bed,
he'd kill them all with the slight of
his hand running far running fast to the
debt.
Those are the lyrics from a song title
John Wayne Gacy Jr by Sufian Stevens.
It is just one of the countless pieces
of art that have been inspired by this
terrifying serial killer,
John Wayne Gacy.
It was a businessman and a
politician to everyone around him.
He was a sweet and charming that no one
in his life could have a guest that he
dressed up like pogo the clown and
murdered teenage boys after dark.
The Chicago Police Department found
27 bodies buried in his basement.
They knew that his kill count though it
was at least 33 and there could be more
victims that were simply never found.
This story became front page news and
immediately captivated the nation.
The fact that there's a killer
clown truly existed in the world,
struck fear into the hearts
of people everywhere,
believing that they could no longer
trust circus performers around their
children.
The story of John Wayne Gacy has inspired
writers to create their own versions
of killer clowns,
including pennywise from Stephen King
as well as twisty the clown in American
horror story. And in the upcoming
2019 DC comics film joker,
Joaquin Phoenix portrays the character
by copying pogo the clown's menacing
makeup.
So who was the man behind the face paints?
How did he get this way and why did
he go on such a murderous rampage?
Yeah,
John Wayne Gacy Jr was born in Chicago
on March the 17th 1942 his father,
John Stanley Gacy was a factory worker.
John's father was very much a man's man
who enjoyed sports and drinking bear.
He really wanted a son and he imagined
having a boy to do all over the
traditional father on activities together
with his mother and was a housewife.
He was very sweet and
loving to our children,
John and and named their baby John Jr and
gave him the middle name Wayne so that
he could be named after the
manly cowboy actor. John Wayne.
Growing up with the family calls him.
Johnny John Senior was a very strict
disciplinarian and are raging alcoholic
because of his outbursts.
It's Johnny spent more time with
his mother and sisters, John Senior.
I've tried to play sports with him in
the backyards and go on weekend fishing
trips, but the boy was never
really very interested.
He preferred to plant flowers, cook and
do traditionally feminine activities.
His father was extremely disappointed in
Jonny, so he constant Nicodemus Sissy.
He asked him if he was trying to be a
girl and forbidden from doing the hobbies
that he actually enjoyed.
Johnny's mother would spoil him with
food in an attempt to make up for his
father's abuse since he became overweight.
There's parents who are constantly
arguing and it would often escalate into
flights.
When his father drank,
he would beat Johnny and his sisters
with a leather and raise a strap.
For many years.
The children would cry out in pain,
but one day during a
particularly bad wedding,
it was like a switch just
flipped and Johnny's brain.
He stopped crying and
he hardly even flinched.
This only made us father more angry and
he proceeded to beat him even harder.
One day,
Johnny passed out when he was playing
with his friends and he was taken to the
hospital where they diagnosed him with
a heart condition and with that it was
official.
John Wayne Gacy would never be an athlete.
No matter how hard his father
pushed him to play sports,
he could not physically handle running
without his heart. Just giving out.
In 1954 Johnny joined the boy scouts
and he became good friends with a boy
called Barry,
but Shelly,
Johnny felt that he could trust
Barry with his biggest secret.
He stole a pair of panties and
a bra from his mother's bedroom.
When he was alone,
he would dress up as a woman and
stares at himself in the mirror.
Sometimes he would put on lipstick and
I wonder if he really should have been
born a girl.
There was clear that Johnny was
questioning his gender identity and his
sexuality.
It must have been obvious to the rest
of his family too because John Senior
would often say that he would rather
his son be dead than find out he was a
homosexual. Even though his
father was clearly abusive,
Johnny was still desperate to be the son.
His father always wanted these,
started to date girls and
tried to have a normal life,
but he was bullied in
school for being overweight.
Since having his heart condition,
it would seem that no matter how
hard he tried to suppress it,
John Wayne Gacy could never fit into
the world that he was born into.
As soon as he graduated from high school,
John Wayne Gacy was 18 years old sins.
He wants you to get as far away from
his hometown as he possibly could.
He moved to the city of Springfield
where he became a shoe salesman in a
department store.
After work,
he became the assistant precinct
captain for the Democratic Party.
He started dating one of his coworkers,
Marion and Meyers.
Her father was wealthy and well
connected in Springfield politics. Gacy.
Told his friends and family that someday
he wants it to become the governor of
Illinois and maybe even the presidents
of the United States. A few years later,
he married Marilyn Mazda's.
He was far from a faithful partner on the
day Marilyn was in the hospital giving
birth to their first child.
John Wayne Gacy was at a bar
with one of his male coworkers.
They got drunk and went back to gacys
house and had sex. Just a few hours later,
his first child was born.
John Senior came to see
his new grandchild's and
for the first time in John
Wayne Gacy his life,
his father said that he was proud of him.
John's new father in law owns several
KFC restaurant franchises or 24 he left
his job selling shoes and became a
manager of one of these restaurants.
According to his best friend,
Barry.
Gary at wanted the job very badly because
he wanted to be able to control people.
John Wayne Gacy continued to climb
the ladder with local politics.
He was always studying people around him
and trying to figure out how he could
make everyone liked him.
He built a full service bar in the living
room of his house and he convinced his
wife that they needed to throw swingers
parties together. If you're not aware,
this is where couples would show up
and switch spouses for the night.
This was popular back in the 1960 since
everyone was raving about the new free
love movements.
The gay were also known to host massive
orgies and they're hiring these sex
parties made John Wayne Gacy
popular almost immediately
until he became the vice
presidents of the local council.
They also voted as a man
of the year at the time,
homosexual men usually led double lives.
Whenever they wanted to have gay sags,
they would start cruising.
Men would take a walk in the park or
down the road late at night waiting for
another man to approach.
They would have sex scenes often would
never see one another again. However,
since he was a public figure,
it's possible that John Wayne Gacy
thought that it would be too risky to have
sex with any adult who
might know who he is.
He decided to go out to people that
he felt he could easily control.
The invited a 15 year old boy named
Donald Voy. Here's over to his house,
the new Donald, because he worked with
his father who was a local senator.
Donald's looks up to John like
a cool older brother ends.
He offered to let Donald drink
alcohol and cs porn collection.
After the boy he got drunk.
He forced Donald to have oral sex with
him when it was over at Gacy threatened
the boy by saying that he
had connections with the mob.
If he ever told anyone he would send
someone to kill him and his family.
When Gacy dropped Donald Hall,
here's off at home,
he gave him $50 in exchange for
the boys. Silence don't. Overall,
he has kept that night to
secret for a very long time,
but he was never at the same again.
In 1968 he broke down and told
his family what had happened.
When he was 15 John Wayne
Gacy was arrested for sodomy.
He swore that he did not do it
and asked for a lie detector test.
He was convinced that
he could fool the test,
but he ultimately failed when
he was called out on this line.
He tried to claim that the sex
with Donald was consensual.
Several of the teenage boys then came
forward to say that there had been raped
by an Gacy as well. He was found guilty
and do a sentence to 10 years in prison.
His wife divorced him and she did
not want him to see their children.
Never again. Now, this could
have been the end of it all,
but unfortunately Gacy used his charm
to schmooze his way into the hearts of
everyone in the prison.
Once he was behind bars,
he made friends with other
inmates as well as the gods.
Since he had experience working a KFC,
he was able to become the head chef in
the kitchen. He received a lot of praise,
but knowing how to properly spice food
and Z was even interviewed for a local
television program called
Christmas at an a Mosa.
Oh,
I've been here now a year and up to weeks.
You know, you pick up right here. Hello.
I hope to be getting out of time and me
all of his father's phase,
no bed come true.
John Xenia died as soon as
this son went to prison.
John Wayne Gacy believed that his father,
he died from shame.
He became so angry that he lashed out
his anger on any gay man he came into
contact with. While in prison he
spotted two men having oral sex,
so he bashed in one of the men's faces
and said it was bloody just by being
found guilty for raping multiple boys.
John Wayne Gacy was released after
just 16 months on good behavior.
He returned to cook county where he lived
with his mum, people in his hometown.
They didn't know about his conviction
and they just remembered him as a young
and innocent boy fat kid
with a heart condition,
so it was very easy for him
to get a fresh start in life.
He found a job as a short order cook
and he saved up his money by working
overtime.
Once he had enough money,
he started a construction
company called PDM contractors.
He also jumps back into local politics.
Newly divorced.
Gary started dating a woman that he
knew from high school called Carol Hoff.
She was a cu with two daughters and she
was struggling to make it on well for
that.
John Wayne Gacy was great around kids
and the had a steady job and it was also
ambitious from Carol's perspective.
He was a catch and his daughter
started to call him daddy right away.
He admitted to Carol that he was bisexual,
but he never told her
about his time in jail.
She accepted him for who he was and
in that moment he had everything,
but he was never satisfied.
In fact,
he felt that had been in prison so long
is craving to have sex with teenage boys
that only been amplified.
One night's John Wayne Gacy was hanging
out at the Greyhound bus station.
He spotted a 16 year
old's name is Tim Mccoy,
who was traveling during Christmas time
and had a brief layover in Chicago.
Gacy started flirting with him and his
offer to show them around the city.
Tim So assumes that this was just a
typical cruising fling. They had sex,
but Casey was angry at himself
for giving into his homosexuality.
He impulsively grabbed a kitchen knife
and stabs him in the chest multiple times.
He buried the boy in the debasement
crawlspace underneath his house.
Tim's parents never saw him for Christmas.
Indeed,
it would be years before they found
out about the fate of their son.
John Wayne Gacy got married to Carol
seven months later and she moved into the
house with her daughters.
His new wife would have no idea that
she was moving into a house where the
remains of a young buyer were
buried right below her feet.
John Wayne Gacy continued to
suppress as homosexual urges.
Instead of putting on lipstick,
though he started to paint
his face in clown makeup.
Normally clown does have
friendly curved features,
but Gacy painted on sharp harsh edges.
He called himself at pogo the clown and
started showing up at the local hospital
to do magic tricks for the children
who were sick when he was pogo.
He got to do all the things
that John was not allowed to do.
This escalated to giving
into as indulgences. Again,
burying his victims in the
basements. John's wife, Carol,
was concerned because she could tell
that his personality had drastically
changed after he began to play Pogo,
John refused to have sex with her.
He made her feel worthless.
They filed for divorce in 1975 when
he was 33 years old. After that,
he was free to hunt teenage
boys as often as he wanted.
He would drive around town
dressed in his full clown makeup.
If he saw a boy walking alone at night,
he would hold up a gun and
forced them into the car.
He would rape and stab them before
burying them again in the basement.
Burying all of those bodies.
It was hard work.
So he brought in one of his new employees,
David Cram,
to dig holes in the basements.
The claims that he needed to add
a new piping under the house,
but he was under strict orders to
avoid certain areas of the basement.
David had no idea that John Wayne Gacy
was forcing him to dig his own grave
crime was from out of town and he
told Gacy that he was looking for new
apartments.
Gacy offered to rent in
one of the bedrooms of his
house in exchange for Labor
one night though pogo the clown walk
through the door and David Cram was
confused. John was already drunk and
his makeup was sliding off his face.
He wasn't acting like John Anymore.
He spoke in a nasally high
pitched voice like a clown,
and to ask David if he wants it to my tie,
David and assumes that this was some
kind of joke. So he agreed to drinks.
Pogo asked if he would like to see a magic
trick and he put handcuffs on David's
risks. He dangled the cane. Friends
of him giggling like a child,
pogo the clown men started poking.
David's saying, does this get you mad?
What about this? Huh, Huh.
David then threatened to punch
him if he didn't stop it.
Gacy never broke character
in the middle of a sentence.
Pogo started grounding and barking
like a dog. Then he started saying,
in a Singsong your voice, I'm
going to rape you. Over and over.
He tried to force David down onto the
floor or attempting to rip off his pants.
David kicked Gacy as hard as he could
and the clown fell to the floor dropping
the key to the handcuffs.
David was able to escape from the house,
but he never spoke a word
of this incidence to anyone
until many years later.
Others though it wouldn't
be so lucky to escape.
Yeah.
John Wayne Gacy is loss noon.
Victim was a 15 year olds named Robert
piece to work at a desk. Planes Pharmacy.
Gacy had spotted the boy and
a previous shopping trips,
so he showed up at the pharmacy
asking to speak to the owner.
He offered to renovate their pharmacy
and casually asked if he knew of any
teenage boys who were looking for a job
because he was willing to pay $5 an hour
for construction work.
Robert Priest took the bait.
This was double what he
made at the pharmacy.
You so he called up gacys company to
apply later as he left the house piece
smother. Ask him where
he was going. He said,
some contractor wants to talk
to me about a job and he left.
His mother never saw Hassan again.
At this point,
Gacy had run out of room in his basement.
There were already 27 corpses
beneath his house, so pogo the clown,
he have to dump it. Robert
Body in the river. When the
police found Robert Spotty,
it was easy for them to take
testimonies and connect the dots.
They approached John Wayne Gacy,
but he was confident that
he would not be caught.
He even invited the investigators over
to his house for dinner and drinks.
One of the officials could
smell the stench of rotting
corpses coming up through
the evidence.
They came back with another Warren sins,
uncovered the bodies of the
teenage boys in the basements.
When John Wayne Gacy was
brought into custody,
the police were preparing
to take his mugshots.
They were asking him basic information
like his name and his birthdate,
and officer asked him, where were
you born? Gacy replied out of chaos.
He started to laugh at his own joke.
The camera flash did.
That very moment is capturing the image
of a murderer who was truly pleased with
himself when they found the bodies.
Gacy knew that he was done.
He quickly claims that he had multiple
personality disorder and that he had no
control over what pogo the clown did,
but clearly he had planned rob piece.
It's murder for a long time
after a psychological evaluation.
It was obvious to anyone that he
was just trying to plea insanity,
but that he seemed to be fully aware
of what he was doing during his trial,
and Casey had the best defense team.
Anyone could ask for it because
of his ties to local governments.
When he received the death penalty,
he actually congratulated his team as
this was the result he wanted. All along.
While in prison,
John Wayne Gacy began to draw pictures
of clowns and sold his artwork.
During every interview he did behind bars,
Gacy claims that he was
innocent and refuse to take
blame for any of his actions.
I want point even decided to write a
book where he claimed that the bodies in
his basement, we're part of a set up to
ruin his political career. May the 10th,
1994 was the day of his execution.
Crowds of people stood outside the prison,
Sean's and kill him, kill him, uh,
holding up signs when it was announced
that he had died from lethal injection.
The crowds,
Chad immediately following his death,
forensic psychologists dissected
gacys body and removed his brain.
They wanted to see if there
were any abnormalities.
There might give them some kind of clue
as to why he had become a serial killer,
but there was nothing to be
found. Even to this day. Experts,
it's still debating on how
to diagnose John Wayne Gacy.
He has been called a sociopath or
psychopath, a paranoid schizophrenia,
some of agreed with his self-diagnosis
of dissociative identity disorder.
What we know for sure though,
is that if it were not for all
the shame he endured or Liz life,
these killings may never have
happened in the first place.
So I hope you found that
video. Interesting. If you did,
give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe. Also,
if you're looking for something
else to watch right now,
why not check out some videos from our
archives or why not check out my other
channel or today I found out you'll find
a link to that below, and as always,
thank you for watching.